should we do some stretches before we
start today because yeah
you need to limber up so we can go
global especially as pewdiepie has been
having a go at you
but he said i'm sick of scruffy little
youtubers uh
you know sitting in their bedrooms and
commenting on things i'm not in my i'm
in my living room so yeah
but you said you sleep on the couch and
you fall asleep drunk you said you get
very sleepy after the wanks
i told you
genuinely though i got a vpn today and i
thought we could uh go global on youtube
and find out
go flat earth yeah please i found
flutter i thought what we could do is go
around the world and find out
what is trending in other countries not
immediately these are not just the same
[__] tv nate shores in america
everywhere i'll be honest i don't know
so we're going to find out but we could
go to venezuela brazil
i hope you liked it oh yeah
we're jumping and jamming we're driving
pregnant uk girl who joined isis says
she'd do anything to come home how about
not join isis in the first place
oh no you can't go back in time unless
isis has got a time machine at which
point
[__] me they are gonna win what's
happened here is there was a young girl
who was lured into isis
i think she was muslim in the first
place right and so people saw this as a
natural road towards her being
radicalized
graduation not at all graduation because
she was sucked in by the glitz and the
glam you know the hollywood
i wouldn't know what the lure is exactly
like what is the reward system maybe she
likes a bad boy yeah these regular
muslims just praying every day and going
about their normal lives just on cutting
it for me they're not doing it when i
get [__] off them
i've got to freak myself off and think
that he would suicide bomb someone just
to come
tell me you'd suicide bomb things oh oh
how many would you kill would you kill
innocent babies oh
oh yeah oh i'm close i'm close
tell me you hate western ideology i hit
the
anyway love i've got to be off i've got
a beheading at six
you know when you die if you're a member
of isis you get many virgins
or the irony is if you die in isis
you get male virgins that is ironic as
[__] isn't it
joke is on them ultimately do you know
what i mean imagine how disappointed
they're going to be they blow themselves
to smithereens
yeah and then they're finally like right
this is it this is what i did it for so
where's the virgin surrounded by men and
all the men are going sorry oh
hello sorry uh oh uh hello oh you liked
it for the virgins as well they go
in a way oh hello darling oh hello look
at you you're looking fantastic
it's great and fine to be gay we're in
support of that but the irony is for an
isis person if there's one thing that
isis don't want to be
it is gay all right do problems with
your problems write in right
i'm a member of isis but i'm gay what do
i do i'm worried that my leader is also
gay heaps look at me in a certain way
he's quite camp
and he looks at his lips a lot he licks
his lips a lot he just pulls out the
rocket launcher and starts polishing it
and looking at me
at the same time just polishing away and
he said i can't wait for this to explode
at the end
he says imagine this imagine this was a
giant [__] we've all seen brokeback
mountain
i can't think of anything more gay than
running off with a load of men to live
in the mountains and polish weapons
yeah together do we need to dress up in
camel gear
no nobody else is around yeah no one's
going to say a spot it just looks so
good on me if you don't want to get
caught [__] in the bushes camo is the
ultimate way to hide yourself she turned
her back on britain at 15
she was below a certain age she didn't
know what she was doing some people are
saying
but also people are saying well when
you're 15 you know by that point the
difference between good and bad if you
were the home office or the homo office
as uh isis call it i think if she
cooperates with the with the um
the forces and and tells them everything
that they want to know
where the people are etc etc fair enough
yeah but you've got to
be team uk then yeah and i think that we
should
start calling ourselves team uk you know
what i mean team tree
we are team gb i want to shia leading
anthony joshua's next fight
and i think in many ways that's what
anthony won so anthony joshua's next
fight
has been revealed made a video about it
i just want you to see
what you pick up from this video good
morning good afternoon and good evening
to fight fans and sports fans from
across the world i hope you're all well
on june the 1st
i'm going to be defending my heavyweight
championship titles at msg
aka madison square gardens you know when
i go i really love
lfc i don't go aka liverpool football
club the reason you shorten things
to just a little acronym right so you
don't have to say the long
words go into the go into the usa what
the united states of america
next month i'm going to the ufc yeah aka
the ultimate fighting challenge
i'm going to be defending my heavyweight
championship titles at msg
aka madison square gardens against the
fight our name jerome miller aka big
baby miller
live on sky sport we're gonna be live on
sky sports aka the people who do sports
on tv
anthony where are you going going
downstairs your whittle aka
pp you know the current state of the
heavyweight division right now is full
of boxing politics
but you know how it goes i just gotta
roll with the punches quite literally
anthony
that's your job though in it it's all so
funny because he goes i've got to roll
with the punches aka boxing
and yeah my feet are firmly on the
ground i'm not looking too far ahead
i'm looking forward to the challenge new
york we're coming for that w
aka the win so basically
the fight everybody wanted for a long
time was tyson fury
or deontay wilder versus anthony joshua
the one thing i forgotten about this
video is who's facing aka
his opponent miller aka big baby miller
can you tell he's not really
enthusiastic about this
he's bored by it why should we be
interested as i was watching i was like
you look defeated mentally like because
he really wanted that big fight i think
oh my god it's rocky my fear
finally the rock is back in philadelphia
should we fight but if that was the way
wwe was it wouldn't work
oh my god captain america i'm gonna beat
you clearly
yeah he ain't happy about it and i just
thought it was the least enthusiastic
fight announcement i've ever seen in my
[__]
life staying in the boxing world we had
a tweet from a young man's father
the young man you can see there he's
about to start boxing final preparations
for fight night on saturday any words of
wisdom to help motivate
zachary for his first fight to chris
eubank look how sweet zachary looks and
his father oh it's adorable don't do it
zachary if you take a boxing
you can never fight outside the ring you
have to always protect people
you have to be continuously chivalrous i
don't know why
being a fighter means that you have to
open doors for women element of control
and respect
you don't have to give you any money to
do that yes which will give you
distinction
that will make you the odd one out i
think that he puts his whole being the
odd one out as a boxing thing he doesn't
realize that even in boxing
he is the weirdo but anyway because you
will become a hero to the masses
which is very lonely you will feel
lonely
if you drive a big truck and live at the
dorchester hotel in london yeah because
no one else can afford to live there
permanently yes oh sullivan said jesus
christ wish him a bit of luck man
yeah and someone else said mate he's
been doing boxing not transforming into
batman
he views this as the butterfly effect he
is coming in
to change the future zachary little
zachary
barely can read he's going to read that
and go i'm hanging the gloves up that's
it this isn't for me
sorry dad this man that i know nothing
about and have no context about is
warning me not to box
he used to be a really good boxer back
in the day so he's
celebrity big brother in all of the
other celebrity washed up shows
moving into youtube now moving in but
still kind of boxing
the ksi logan paul beef just lingers
logan paul's girlfriend or ex-girlfriend
now
tweeting ksi logan's done well with the
women honey
you got you got what's her name chloe
bennett chloe [__] bennett chloe
[__] bennett she was hot she was hot
in german uh karina kopp means karina
head
he has a type done he he goes for those
pretty sort of
i see what your type is attractive women
will have eyes that do this
instagram model karina kopf karina head
in english
could be in hot water she probably takes
a bath every day after
being involved in an incriminating
series of social media interactions with
youtuber ksi
hi ksi i'm in london love heart she said
that
right and then ksi had put out a
instagram story saying you helped me
keep going when i feel lost it was a
very like romantic
loving instagram story i love you see
now a lot of people
put two and two together and got five
when they thought that these two were
connected they're not connected they're
not do you know why
let me show you this x and c are next to
each other on the keyboard
ksi has boxers thumbs he just meant to
put
x he actually put c case closed
aka end of the story oh there's another
person with the name c who he actually
meant to fall in love not many people
with the name
c and there's a problem i can't think of
another catherine
catherine starts with a k [__] benny
chloe
i've seen catherine's with c's all right
[__] off i think that this is
logan's best mate he goes this is the
most petty [__] i ever seen in my life
seek help so then she's replied yeah it
was a pretty bad joke
silly me so she feels a bit bad for it
now after keem tweeted it as well so she
clearly wants people like keem to be
involved and so yeah she's she's loving
a bit of she knows keem's playing the
flute at the side
so basically nothing happened it was a
storm in a teacup but
what i think is interesting is whenever
someone falls out with one of these two
guys they instantly go to the other one
to make the other one mad me and you
fell out and i just became an arsenal
fan out of nowhere and started
being on all sorts of little beanie and
just going like oh it's unacceptable
mate we can't be playing like this i'd
literally look at you and i feel sorry
for you
so this is a new jumper available at
gucci which obviously wasn't very well
thought through
offensive to a lot of people basically
wasn't it there was a time
where a lot of people might not know who
watched this where white entertainers
would
dress up as black entertainers and
they'd black up as they say basically
have their lips
showing a bit like what she's got there
yeah a very similar way
gucci are getting hammered for this
naturally they are saying it's
unintentional uh
maybe it is maybe it's just terrible
fashion if there's one person
who doesn't give a [__] what gucci are
doing the black people it's floyd
mayweather
i think my dad needs to stop boxing he
older but you know what i'm going to go
into
oh right so gucci i know you've been a
long time supporter are you still
supporting after
all controversies what controversy
bearing in mind at this point the whole
world knows about the controversy
except floyd mayweather i'm sure you
heard you know you know
they had the blackface sweater and you
know a lot of prominent not a [__]
clue
his mind is going blackface uh sweater
okay yeah uh because everybody say uh
where it is
or don't wear this i'm worried what the
[__] i want to wear i'm about to go in
the goose
oh [__] me you [__]
you know when people are so stupid they
think they're smart that's him that's
him that is in my head i've always
thought about flying he's so
[__] rich because of boxing in his
head he's like no i'm rich because i'm a
genius yeah
like you know you're not you said
they're gonna be upset with me right
there i love it i love it i
love it let black people be upset with
him all right when he was stood outside
the gucci
he processed it for a minute and thought
like for a second it was like i'm going
in here
so whatever happens i'm just gonna like
own it liam neeson's pr people must have
been like
thank you floyd i live with myself i do
what i want to do when i want to i want
to
i'm not a follower follows 500 people on
twitter 515 to be exact
i got friends from all walks of life
brilliant he loves a racist yeah
hanging out with them all the time that
guy behind him massive racist massive he
just keeps them around just keep him
grounded
yeah and to me of course black lives
matter
first phrase but fair enough i don't
think that's the black lives matter
probably more than other lives i don't
think that's how they were
not what you were saying but um i
haven't showed them a while on social
media so
i think i'm gonna uh show one of my
bulgari's actually tonight do you ever
just take pictures of your possessions
oh i've got a new kettle
best take a picture of it do you know
what i mean no there's another way it
works
but sometimes cars they say you take
them off the latte you know
what do you think i love how how this
guy's basic
abc questions confuse flights so much
what's the best investment out right now
as far as money-wise i'm not giving
nobody no
you don't give investment tips i'm not
giving no investment tips you don't have
any investment
tips you go into shops and buy things
that's not investing
that's buy it you know his business he
literally right gets punched in the face
for a living and then he owns a few
strip clubs yeah the guy is
but he's very brought into good business
he likes men are always going to want
tits yeah
investment tits yeah a lot of you out
there young businessmen and women
wanting tips um
first tip don't get punched in the face
while boxing and
do it for a lot of money set up strip
clubs because men will always like tits
what which cities would you set these
strip clubs up um texas
texas that's a state but i'll give it to
you new york
new york again a state but i'm assuming
you mean the city
atlanta atlanta you finally nailed it
atlanta georgia because in those places
people love titties
kenny g delighted when kanye sorry kim
kardashian delighted when kanye west
decorated their home in roses
and there's kenny good kanye really get
down and decorate or did he just pay
people to do it
[Applause]
now he's very romantic i love the fact
that kanye's had all of these put down
yeah and
kenny's just right there and that was
only oh my
knocks over another i don't know that in
another and then he turns on and they're
all smashed on the floor there's roses
everywhere
and he goes sorry kanye and kanye is
just [__] raging i will never sample
you again
oh look how happy he is though he is
very happy
it was valentine's day so i get that but
it's it's very much like shouldn't it
just be about
used to being happy together i got
kenny j [__] off i don't think that's
how kanye did it oh yeah i got box of
chocolates and some roses
what did you get quality street what did
you get kenny g kenny
i think he's like what the [__] do i
need to do do you have some to get
something
yeah she's like kanye get off me and
he's like [__] me i gotta ring kenny g
up here sort this out
well originally he was gonna get the
game to stand in the middle but it got a
little awkward if you know what i mean
yeah
after the game skull [__] her back
when they do do you think he did what's
a skull [__] brian youtube searched the
game
and he'll tell you
it's a good line though isn't it i made
her swallow my kids until she choked
the problem that they've got is now
everyone's basically hint and they
[__] kim
in kanye's mind kim k is like the new
modern day marilyn monroe like the
unattainable
only [__] by like jfk and [__]
frank sinatra
the top dogs of that era got to [__]
marilyn monroe
she's just been [__] by a lot of
rappers so when they first
um this video today is something that i
just
i have to make because like it's out
there
after this obviously me and jason are
done which is so
heartbreaking to me because um i love
him
so much jason's also the guy who's in
the videos with david dobrik he's the
older guy
that's our fella yeah that's her
boyfriend yeah yeah so let's find out
what the [__] going
that on got with her yeah and i felt
like it's like a
big middle-aged press yeah basically
yeah so brian here's
his little compilation of trisha it's 10
minutes of her being toxic and abusive
you and i have different ears for sure
yours are big mine are small
vine was so big and then like it's fun
to just watch something for seven
seconds it's like it really gives your
brain a rest you know it looks like
you're an idiot
i see why men like her though why
there's just sass and
bitchiness and he's like a blonde chubby
girl jeremy and she's not
she's quite overtly sexual and some men
would find her attractiveness do you
know what i mean
i got married before it was like you
know
rough it was rough because when you hand
over that kind of [__] commitment to
a woman sometimes it turns them into a
nut case and and i can tell
she would go nuts with that once she's
got you like a [__] black widow
spider you're [__] so in the squid
world
right go on i'll go with it just to see
where the journey takes us men get horny
before women do bit like humans when
they're hungry women sort of use their
sexuality in the squid game to lure
amani and once he sort of attaches his
uh
penis or whatever it is they eat the man
and they faced on the caucus for like a
week
afterwards they use their [__] to lure
the man in
they live off of him they get him to
work for them and provide for them
and then they slowly but surely crush
his soul can we go back to
the crying video then so i've got a bit
of context now and i'm just gonna put it
all out on this video and i'm starting
with david
because even though jason's creepy and
disgusting
would you be happy if trisha paytas
broke up with you and went
brian is creepy and disgusting i think
that's a horrible thing to say about
someone yeah he's probably just a
[__] bloke he's probably the normal
bloke this guy there was a vlog where i
take all my clothes off in david's house
because i'm so pissed i'm just
so pissed have you ever been so angry
you take all your clothes off i love it
when i've got a shirt on and i'm just
arguing with a woman and i'm like
you just [__] you're disgusting
biggest [__] [__] i
swear to god that i've ever met in me
like that would look really weird if you
went i am so angry i need to take on my
childhood i think it would actually
scare a woman if i started undressing
that would terrify your woman be safe
what the [__] are you doing me put them
back on that's so unusual isn't it yeah
trisha we wish you all the best i hope
that you recover from this good luck
trish you need anyone to [__] you
to be honest no but she's attracted to
creepy men
in other news so basically this girl
claims that she is madeline mccann
that does look like someone who could be
like a young picture of her doesn't it
they both have mouths and eyes and noses
i wouldn't be surprised if the macans
were like oh yeah
that she's what ah
definitely not her but [__] me the heat
is on us right now we need to you said
you disposed of the body
i did oh lovely to see you where have
you been all these things
all these years do you remember anything
that happened because if you said you
killed it if you did then
please go home do you have an opinion on
it ah
it's more of a i don't really give a
[__] it's another girl gone
kind of thing the one thing that really
made me like
all the questions uh mrs mcconnel would
not answer after she was
taken into custody by the police and a
lot of the questions
about her daughter would help would have
helped them try and locate
all the basics of the last time you've
seen her she refused to answer so many
of them
in the immediate aftermath and that
almost left me like why you know i've
been questioned by police before if
you've done nothing wrong
you tell everyone everything you know
yeah and that always just [__] with me a
bit like i'm like nah this is dark [__]
whatever happened it's dark as [__] oh
who the [__] is that
so her name is jeremy rose demi rose
ryan look her up on instagram for
yourself
jesus she is unreal is this your kind of
girl brian
do you like girls every man on the
planet would say that
she would turn james charles that girl
your doctor tells you about trintellix
a prescription medicine for depression
so you're feeling this
overall relief and trintellix had no
significant impact on weight in clinical
trials
you've got this tell your doctor right
away if you have worsening depression
unusual changes in mood behavior or
thoughts of suicide manic episodes or
vision problems may occur in some people
because
manic episodes may occur in some people
what the [__] are we what this wasn't
part of true news like this is just
this has just come on randomly you see
how casually they talk about depression
this is mental yeah
no wonder america as [__] can you
imagine them having that kind of advert
on the
in the uk tv people go crazy yeah that
is mental
[Music]
one of the first things i remember
drawing was the genie in aladdin wow
like i loved that movie yeah it was a
great film wasn't it a little street rat
yeah you could be aladdin you're the rat
oh yeah good point um arsenal nights
like arsenal day
bring me the land jafar was an old man
that he doesn't look old enough for a
star and another thing is jafar had a
really um
yahoo like a very dark deep vibe now
he's like
bring me the lamp
i mean he's a good-looking guy he
doesn't look the way i imagined him to
look
straight right i'm looking at a survivor
someone who
looks like he could handle himself
someone who looks like a bit of a tough
guy
a bit more manly than that yeah he just
looks soft as [__]
you really don't know who i am genie
wishes lamb
none of that ringing a bell i like will
smith but stick to youtube what you're
good at
will smith's career has just nosedived
doesn't it and now it's like
can he do that can he do with the genie
it's impossible
to follow robin williams you're
following an actor who was
beloved in the time when he was the
actor has died since and the greatest at
what he did
do you know ironically who who i would
have had ninja i'm not just saying this
steven tries i feel like you need a
different direction
so you don't go directly head to head
and i feel like will smith is just going
to come across as a bit of a crap
genie british of this oh yeah oh i've
been in that lab so long i've been all
out of recognition
[Music]
boys and girls roll up because this
video just
is gonna be absolutely raucous
here i go to get the tattoo that i only
got
six months ago lasered off this was me
after literally the first day of getting
it done
i felt a bit like this before really
yeah i mean i think with this one
i i got home and i was like that's not
what i wanted when it's being
constructed on your skin
tattoos you only really know exactly
what they're going to look like by the
time they're finished
all right boys and girls it's currently
6 a.m i mean i've got the shake so
yeah it's all i do did you feel like i'm
off my head you will be
um when you're getting tattooed
especially for the length of time you
sat there you're not eating
you're losing blood you're in pain and
you're just sitting there and it's
happening for hours
and hours and hours he put himself
through hell basically
but anyways boys and girls it then got
even worse
i got home and then it all started
crumbling off
and like what is that that's very normal
sometimes even if you look after them
they will just drop the ink will drop
out and and it will need going over and
going over and going over this is where
you get it lays that off you know when
oil spits at you out of a frying pan
right like that like repeatedly
oh [__] son oh you put a bastard i think
this is a really good video from joe
he's got a huge kid audience right yeah
they're all gonna be like i want to get
a tattoo when i'm 16 17 18.
wait this is exactly how so many people
do they make a snap judgment on a tattoo
and they just get any old [__] and then
they hate it for the rest of their life
now look at lee for joy can afford to do
something about it
but sometimes this [__] costs a lot of
money then you also you don't want to
have to do something
you want to be in agony while you're
having to do it as well so this is a
really good video
to the point where i'm going to get some
removed which ones i'm going to get this
one done
ticking off yeah do you know who's going
to do it joe i don't know for sure but
dr resho
who we had on the podcast has offered to
do it for us
wow it's inspired me to sort my now
because i'm really not happy with this
one
you have been inspired by a youtube
video this is the opposite of what true
news normally is cheers
you're going to be in my belly today
y'all bro these are an airpods ball this
is a
flex mobile that even in your mouth is
huge
right i mean i've swallowed like big
bits of meat before that are bigger than
that though you can choose
to say geo do not cut that out of
context yeah i really didn't think that
through no
we've been recording for a while i'm
sorry i'm not well come on
one go oh my god that that's not nice
though
oh my god i watched this um
horror channel recently like the guy the
man he talks like this and he tells you
lots of stories yeah there was a haunted
house
that became suddenly unexpectedly even
more haunted
yeah when teenagers go down to the local
house they find
crazy things i was watching that channel
the other day that
rob horror channel guy he told the story
about how his kid
ate a slug and it had like things in it
that eventually like killed the boy
who ate it like he got dead to eat a
slug
and the guy was like yeah okay i'll eat
the slug or whatever it like
just you could have infections or yeah
they had all sorted and i'm just
watching these two swallowing this thing
and what these idiots didn't realize
was that airpods were poised [__]
dead within a week or whatever it's got
meat uh
it's not like meat is it it's got like
metal in there yeah they're not supposed
to ingest this
no never this is something we just say
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
apple products will likely kill you yes
very much so in fact
and that's all we have for today
unfortunately i haven't been too well
uh wish me wish me to get well soon
everyone if you could thanks
for everyone who regularly tunes into
true news whatever the story we're
talking about
it doesn't matter the most important
thing is it's us uh see you next week
for more true news
aka true news news that's true
bye bye see you later aka goodbye good
luck
good take care aka adios sayonora
au revoir aka auf wiedersehen